okay so this is what I think HTML
response turns into tokens which turns
into nodes which turn into the Dom tree
that one is true that's the process we
just learned in this one each token like
start tag and end tag get converted into
Dom nodes this is in fact false a single
Dom node will start with a start tag
token and end with an end tag token
between the start tag and end tag tokens
come other tokens which will define one
Dom node in this one nodes contain all
relevant information about the HTML
element this is true the information
will be described using tokens and the
last one nodes are connected into a Dom
tree based on token hierarchy this one
it is true if another set of start tag
and end tag tokens come between start
tag and end tag you have a node inside a
node and this is how we define the
hierarchy of the Dom tree lastly it's
also worth noting that Dom construction
is incremental